le gouvernement a décidé d'arrêter les
aides forfaitaires dont de mettre fin au
fond d'eux
au fonds de solidarité le 30 septembre
et il voudrait passer à des êtres qui
serait plus ciblée alors à la fois sur
des secteurs qui ont plus souffert comme
par exemple le secteur de l'événementiel
le secteur du tourisme d'affaires
et ils voudraient aussi le recentrer sur
des entreprises qui ont besoin après ça
va quand même posé un problème de calcul
et ont ces temps de rentrée c'est une
page de la crise sanitaire qui va
bientôt se tourner la fin du quoi qu'il
en coûte lancé en mars 2020 à la fin du
mois donc ces aides auront dans leur
ensemble écouter quelques 240 milliards
d'euros au budget d'état mais avec quels
résultats peut-on vraiment croire un
arrêt total de ces aides sont elles se
poursuivent d'une façon ou d'une autre
on voit se fait tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir c'est notre
rubrique l'édito échos
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques sapir merci d'être un
jour chair et en os sur le plateau je
suis ravi de vous y accueillir alors
évidemment la question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui qu'on craint d'ailleurs
est-ce que les tares à ccc z avec un
retour à la quasi normale qui se profile
jacques oui alors effectivement on
s'attendait même certains le redoutent
et on s'attendait justement à ce que ce
soit la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte alors
il faut toujours rappeler que ce quoi
qu'il en coûte il a coûté rien que pour
le soutien à l'économie
240 milliards d'euros c'est ce qu'a dit
olivier du soft le ministre du budget
est globalement évidemment si on prend
l'ensemble des sommes qui ont été
déboursés sur 2020 sur 2021 et qui le
seront encore 2022 on attend 4 124
milliards d'euros ça fait beaucoup donc
est-ce que le gouvernement va pouvoir
arrêter le robinet comme cela d'un coup
ou bien est-ce qu'il sera contraint
d'une certaine manière de continuer d
aide c'est aussi une question qu'il faut
poser et j'avoue que on peut quand même
douté d'un arrêt immédiat du quoi qu'il
en coûte alors reprenons un petit peu
les choses par le début d'où vient ce
crois qu'il en coûtait et quel bilan
peut-on en tirer bien emmanuel macron a
dit évidemment le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est pour sauver l'économie il l'a
répété plusieurs fois ne serait ce que
dans son allocution du 12 juillet
dernier bon il faut savoir qu'à partir
du moment où l'état imposé à certaines
entreprises de manière administrative de
fermer du fait de la pandémie et des
fallait compenser le manque à gagner
donc d'une certaine manière oui sur quoi
qu'il en coûte ils étaient obligés après
c'est vrai que l'état fait beaucoup il a
fait beaucoup mais est on le voit sur le
graphique pas nécessairement plus que
d'autres pays la france se situe à peu
près au milieu et puis il faut quand
même dire une chose c'est que ce quoi
qu'il en coûte il a été distribué de
manière assez inégal alors dans quelle
mesure les salariés ont-ils justement
profiter de ces aides vous avez tout à
fait raison stéphanie les salariés ont
été parmi les principaux bénéficiaires
vous savez que dans le quoi qu'il en
coûte 50 % des salariés ont été aidées
vient en particulier le chômage partiel
c'est un chiffre qu'il faut comparer 22%
seulement en italie 20 % en allemagne 11
% en espagne après et bien quand on
regarde le cas des travailleurs
indépendants une autre partie importante
quand même de la population qui
travaille et bien c'est pas du tout
aussi glorieux en ce qui concerne les
travailleurs indépendants on est qu'au
12e rang au niveau européen donc ça
prouve bien que dans ce quoi qu'il en
coûte certains en ont profité et c'est
très bien mais d'autres ont été plutôt
laissé de côté et donc ça plutôt aggravé
les inégalités de ce point de vue là
alors jacques de nouvelle z à la carte a
priori devrait prendre le relais mais
comment ça va se passer concrètement
c'est effectivement la grande question
le gouvernement a décidé d'arrêter les
aides forfaitaires donc de mettre fin au
fond de
vos fonds de solidarité
le 30 septembre et il voudrait passer à
des aides qui serait plus ciblée alors à
la fois sur des secteurs qui ont plus
souffert comme par exemple le secteur de
l'événementiel le secteur du tourisme
d'affaires
et ils voudraient aussi le recentrer sur
les entreprises qui ont besoin après ça
va quand même posé un problème de calcul
alors on peut donc penser un sauf erreur
de ma part que les aides ne s'arrêteront
pas c'est bien cela va votre idée oui
parce que si vous voulez
fondamentalement d'une part il y a le
problème des prêts garantis par litre
alors ces prêts garantis par l'état
important 160 milliards en un an et demi
mais ces prêts garantis par l'état il
faut les rembourser ce sont des prêts de
même qu'il va falloir rembourser
les la dette sociale la dette fiscale là
on parle de report sur 2022 sur 2023
mais ça veut dire qu'il y aura toute une
somme importante qu'il va falloir
rembourser et qui peut poser problème
à des petites et des moyennes
entreprises et puis d'un autre côté on a
des secteurs qu'il va falloir continuer
à aider bien sûr qu'il ya des secteurs
qui ont profité de cette crise vous
savez le e-commerce il se réjouit plutôt
de la crise sanitaire mais il ya
d'autres secteurs qui ont été très
durement touchée et donc si on combine
ce qu'il va falloir donner aux
entreprises
pour qu'elles puissent rembourser il va
falloir que l'état en fait tu payes ce
remboursement d'une certaine manière est
ce qu'il va falloir donner au secteur
qui eux ont beaucoup souffert et qui
n'ont pas encore et qui sont loin
d'avoir retrouvé même le chiffre
d'affaires de 2019 eh bien ça va faire
une certaine somme alors en conclusion
jacques pensez vous que sont d'autres
formes le quoi qu'il en coûte que coûte
va finalement perdurer oui on peut le
penser 1 pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
il ya un fait qui est évident nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une année
préélectorale
si vous voulez on voit bien que le
gouvernement va faire toutes les
dépenses qu'ils estiment nécessaires à
la réélection des manuels macro donc ça
c'est une première chose ensuite il ya
une autre question qui est évidente
c'est justement le fait que si on arrête
ces aides de manière nette
on risque de condamner à mort un nombre
important d'entreprises
le bureau d'études altares estime à 60
milles les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sont dans une situation
de tension financière extrêmement
importante donc ça veut dire que ce mur
des faillites que l'on n'a pas vu pour
l'instant eh bien on pourrait peut-être
le voir en 2022 ça ferait quand même
très mauvais effet en année électorale
d'avoir une vague de faillites et puis
il y a les aides que le gouvernement
veut mettre en place et là c'est
clairement dans une logique
préélectorale le rsa jeunes dont on
parle beaucoup la suppression des impôts
de production c'est une bonne chose mais
ça représente de toutes les manières une
nouvelle aide pour les entreprises et
donc si on combine tout cela bien on
peut penser que le quoi qu'il en coûte
n'est pas tout à fait prêt à s'arrêter
on va savoir si un dossier qu'on va
pouvoir suivre dans les mois qui
on sera réellement fixer vos prévisions
étaient les bonnes merci jacques sapir
d'avoir été avec nous en direct donc sur
ce plateau